foreign
to Alexis in Phoenix hey Alexis what's
happening
hi can you hear me okay absolutely
what's up
all right so I'm 15. my mom just told me
this morning that my parents have had to
dip into their savings the past two
months okay
um she's my mom has stayed home with us
and homeschooled us for 10 years
um and she's going to have to get a
part-time job
um and I'm just wondering like how my
savings and how me saving for my future
fits into that because I kind of feel
guilty
having extra money every month or having
my own money putting into savings while
they're struggling yeah
man they are lucky they're they're lucky
to have you as their kid you are the
oldest 15 year old I've ever taught it's
fantastic okay I'm gonna tell you
something really hard to internalize and
you're gonna hear these words and your
your guts aren't gonna believe me okay
it's not your job
you are doing an incredible job planning
for your future and your parents have
made grown-up choices like whatever job
your Dad is working at is a choice he's
chosen to work and that's his trade
that's what he does
um and your mom made a choice we want to
stay at home that was a collective
values-based decision that they made and
then there's a math problem they ran
into and like adults all over the
country Brave adults are saying okay
this is what we wanted this isn't going
to be this isn't the way this is going
to work out for a while so we're gonna
have to alter our plan and do something
else
and so I'm actually proud of your
parents for doing that it's awesome it's
just going to look different
okay yeah the greatest thing you can do
for your parents is you take care of
your business in the classroom you take
care of your business like as a teammate
around that house right make sure you
take care of your responsibilities with
Excellence which I know you do and be
sober minded be intentional about
planning for the future what college is
going to look like what it's going to
cost where are you going to go what are
you going to study all of those things
that's the way you support your parents
not by taking your part-time job money
and trying to keep the lights on now
they're making a moment when they ask
you for that doesn't sound like that's
what's happening it sounds like your mom
set set you down like a good mom she
actually sounds incredible sat you down
and said hey we've have some hard
realities that we're dealing with and so
I'm gonna have to go to work and so
homes gonna look a little different for
a season is that what happened
yeah I I applaud her because a lot of
parents would try to hide that they'd be
ashamed of that they'd be scared of that
and your mom did the right thing she sat
down and told you a hard truth and that
also means that she trusts you
does that make sense that she thinks
you're wise enough to hear that that
scary that scary stuff okay
but keep that in your mind and in your
heart it's not your job okay yeah
do you believe me
yes no you don't but it's okay it's it's
okay if you don't so there are some
tactical things you can do Alexis one is
you know you're 15 you're starting to
enter that age where you can go get some
part-time jobs and one thing you can do
is instead of going hey Mom and Dad I
want the new iPhone it's twelve hundred
dollars
you can go work for that and save for
that and you cover your own expenses of
things that are kind of the luxuries in
your life you don't have to go pay the
water bill but you can cover you know
going out to the movies with your
friends it sounds like you already do
that yeah oh yeah oh yeah I wasn't sure
if that was okay for me to continue to
have like absolutely I think that's
great yes flexing that muscle at 50. I
wish John and I were that smart at 15.
yes goodness great I didn't know what
day it was when I was 15. and yes you
listen
we often think that pain is some zero or
that grief is some zero and what that
means is that George loses his job
and I get a flat tire
and I am upset I'm whining about my flat
tire and George goes oh yeah you think
that's bad I lost my listen
grief and sadness aren't some zero
you can go have joy while your parents
are making life adjustments at their
home because one doesn't you not you
just sitting at home and not having fun
and not hanging out with your friends
and spending your spending money by
going to the movies you doing that
doesn't help the
the bills get paid you see what I'm
saying
it's just you joining into their misery
into something that you didn't cause
it's not your job okay yeah and so yeah
go have fun with your friends
I love what George says
um if you know hey now's not the time to
go ask for the iPhone whatever 13 or 17
or whatever number they're up to now
that's cool that's fine
um
but do go have joy in your life okay
I'm gonna do one one better for you
Alexis I'm gonna gift you Financial
Peace University and one thing you can
do is you're casually hanging out living
room watching Financial Peace University
and you go hey Mom Dad if you want to
join me like I'm learning so much in
this if you guys want to join me I think
it'd be really cool for us to go through
it together and not as a plate from a
place of Shame of like hey Mom and
you're just tell me you guys are broke
this might be good for you I call them
15 idiots on the radio I got you solved
telling the person who wiped your butt
you know seven years ago this so uh just
go watch it yourself and I think you
modeling that might Inspire them
motivate them give them some hope and
when the time comes you're gonna get
older and they're gonna be asking you
for advice that's right and so it's a
great place to be so hang on the line
Jen is going to pick up we're going to
gift you Financial Peace University for
one year as well as every dollar premium
and you can get on a budget at 15 and
they might see you doing that and go
what was that you did that's pretty cool
go ahead and send her Anthony O'Neill's
um debt-free degree too Jenna um and she
can start reading on now and caboodle
college is going to look look like in
the future